some kind of move here maybe f4 if you
want to keep control of these squares
but after queen takes that light squared
bishop that you're trying to stick black
with is now gone from the board the
other idea of course after knight to g4
is that you could take this knight but
now it's different because suddenly
there's a pawn that's kind of
restricting your king and the move e5 is
not so easy to stop you'd have to play
d4 but you take away the you take away
this d4 square for your knight which you
had won in the first place now it's not
that powerful but you also open up the
possibility of bishop to b5 and suddenly
black's okay did a kobe and maybe miss
this line when he walked into it thought
i'm going to display 95 94 everything's
going to work and then on seeing the
move said wait a second i can't do it
and had to opt for rook c1 maybe that's
what happened and cause him now to just
have instead of what looked like a
really pleasant advantage just a little
bit to work with guys very good
and uh that we do have a couple more
moves b6 was played followed by knight
to e5 by various nikola van will this be
enough for varusian to have a realistic
chance of victory in this game
gatakansky's made his last few moves
rather quickly we criticized him for
getting really low on time but he's made
his last six moves in just uh five
minutes or so so
kind of removing that trouble a little
bit picking up the pace picking up the
pace exactly and varus and kind of
lagging a little bit um and
yeah we will uh we'll have to keep a
close eye on this uh critical battle for
the us championship we'll be right back
after a commercial break
hello and welcome back to the 2014 us
chess championship we just got um an
exciting development in the monar lender
game so let's go right to that uh
speaking of time pressure moelner's
got only 25 minutes to lenderman's 56
minute so that could become a factor
later in the game well we've seen it
consistently in
the play of alex lenderman that he has
outprepared his opponent and not only
the position on the board but also on
the clock has been very favorable for
alex linderman uh we're going to go step
back one two moves with the with the
move queen d5
alex was proposing
a queen trade uh worried about the open
d file and the potential that his bishop
on d3 might be a tactical target max
stepped back with his bishop and now we
see the aggressive central thrust e6 e5
hoping to try to force
white into trading queens
and after say knight f5 let me just put
a lot of swap swap swaps on the board
something of this nature
we could see the rook
black rook coming down to the second
rank
really aggravating whites
pawns on f2 and b2 and getting uh even
though we're dropping the e pawn after
rook takes e5
by bishop f6 exactly
exactly we picked that up and black
would definitely be full of choice i
believe
that instead mac played the movie
and then alex quickly played queen to d7
so he had had his response
prepared for this exactly so bishop b3
hoping that after queen takes
f3 knight takes f3
the pawn on e5 is weak and after for
example e4 suddenly it's white's pieces
that are coordinating attack against the
f7 pawn
definitely lenderman wanted nothing to
do with that he dropped back with his
queen queen came back to d7 stopping the
move knight f5
if white is forced to retreat his knight
for example to either the squares e2 or
c2 then let me just put one move and
that should happen then uh a move like
queen
uh
uh g4 or maybe even queen f5 or queen h3
and we see lenderman taking advantage of
that move h2h4 which didn't feel
very good to me uh
which move did he do did he reach 52 now
okay so queen d7 knights oop i beg your
pardon queen d7 knight
d
knight to uh
c2 was played and now we we we have to
move our queen first of all because we
want to develop the bishop on c8 but
more importantly why does threatening
this move bishop
to b6 with a double attack against the
pawn on e5 as well as the rook on d8 so
black has got to do something
i thought queen g4 was it
queen takes g4 knight takes g4
some position like this
and you still have the possibility of
rook to d2 but then after
but in this case then i can just play
rook to d1
right and you're not in time um and now
actually uh lenderman has played a move
he played queen to c7 instead of playing
queen g4 or h3 or f5 as we thought he
might so keeping queens in the board i
think that was actually the best move
because first of all
which is a very important threat it
covers the pawn on e5 and now the bishop
on c8 is ready to jump to g4 h3 or the
knight on g4 and as we mentioned before
that pawn on h4 creating that weakness
on g4 which is now coming into the play
especially with the queen on f3 exactly
so
if white tries to
highlight the b6 square perhaps by
playing a4 and a5
well first of all you can be stopped but
second of all the bishop g4 is forcing
us to be in ghetto our queen yeah
putting the queen on g2
yeah i'm just better than h1 drew that
uh
just starting to consider ideas
to try to uh cement while you're trying
to cement your bishop on b
on b6 i might start trying to cement my
bishop on f3 and i think the threats
that are closer to the white king are
more serious than what's happening on
the queen side i mean a4 does look a
little slow yeah yeah of course
just as an idea to throw out what white
noise is not completely out of um out of
the question because while you have to
move bishop g4 we can't interpolate the
move rook takes d8 check although now
we've given up the d file right very
helpful uh
series of moves for
right before uh black yeah so white
doesn't so it kind of
makes you wonder
what can white do this active here
exactly maybe just anticipate the g4
square and move the queen preemptively
okay but okay if we move our queen great
so we move our queen the bishop
actually just develops either the g4 or
g4 or f5 black's activity is very
desirable very nice very nice nice
position for alexander and a nice time
on the clock
and we've got another game that's
heating up ramirez robson and maurice
has more on that
well it looks as though in this position
ramirez has just gifted a pawn to his
opponent robson sitting in a good
position in four and a half points
needing a win if you can do it with the
black pieces so much the better going
into the next round there are some
scenarios very
percentage-wise low scenarios that have
him being able to tie for first in the
championship
but he still would have to start by
winning this game and winning the next
one as well but take a look at this
position here
the sacrifice on b4 was played giving
ramirez
an an extra a down a pawn but extra
lines in the position his bishop is
really quite good and he could go after
this knight after he dropped his knight
back with the knight c2 his intention is
certainly to get pressure on this side
but after d5
his chances didn't look that great of
getting any advantage and he can play
for trades on the d5 square to be able
to pick off this pawn on b7 he spent a
long time here he's now at 26 minutes
and 29 seconds and he played the very
strange knight to a4
maybe a little too deep for himself
robson captured on c4 now up two pawns
he is and
in this position knight to c5 attacking
the bishop the problem with this line is
this is a very simple bishop to d5 and
that defends everything if you try to
grab this piece on b7 of course this is
kind of
a night committing suicide by going into
the position not being able to come back
out and any other moves seem dangerous
bishop takes d5 of course is not a move
to consider because after queen takes d5
your knights again under attack and it's
not going anywhere you're down two pawns
and another line to think about would
probably be this capture
taking on c4
winning back one of the pawns but now
after bishop takes on g2 knight takes on
g2 then a simple queen c7 and you really
gotta wonder
what is ramirez thinking about why did
he go down into this line you know he
didn't want to
equalize maybe but this looks like he's
just donating a pawn with no
compensation whatsoever to black all
robson has to do is find these moves i'd
like to make one last point if you look
at lenderman's games the way he's been
playing in this championship even when
he's losing
he's not going low on time his time
management has been superb we're
watching a lot of other players go down
below 20 minutes 10 minutes even down to
the the minute increment we've seen
arena crush go down to two seconds even
one second on her clock but lindemann
has been moving quickly confidently out
preparing his opponents even when he
hasn't done so he's a believer in good
clock management as part of the game and
it looks as though he's definitely
equalized and is thinking about taking
over the initiative in mullner and once
again he's got an advantage on the clock
guys
nice insight thank you maurice i'm
looking at the game between the other uh
game of our co-leader between uh
kobe and uh
and defending champion gotta kamsky
queen trade alert queen training not
quite as exciting as our blunder
sacrifice alerts no exactly
and uh the game has definitely become
boring on the one hand but uh true
happiness for cobian because he's he's
reached i believe uh queen traits have
been played let me make certain of that
but how hard do you think he's going to
play
how how close do you think he's going to
get to the win in this game against this
solid godakamski do you think he has a
realistic chance
i don't even think that uh kobe and his
thinking in that manner i think
the way he's really
his approach to the game is
i would love to win i would really
really really love to win but i just
definitely definitely don't want to lose
because i really got a chance to play
for the national championship in the
final round even if i can't win this
game yeah that's true he's with black
and he if you if the swim ends in the
way that i think it's going to it won't
take him that much more energy and then
he'll have a day to you know more of a
day an evening to prepare for
ramirez so definitely um from that point
of view he's still very much in the
championship but i mean
how do you realistically rate his
chances to win this game again
yeah i see you're saying the better
minor we have the better minor pieces
but what about targets yeah well it's
not really about kamsky it's really
about the position
um
there are several actually there's a lot
of levers in the position the first one
is that white could probably try to play
king
f2 h3 g4 get a favorable situation on
the queen side on the king side
the other uh idea
that if i were white i would really be
going for this b2b4 idea so i'll just
put some moves on the board and try to
show you
where i'm
thinking the game might be heading i put
my king on d2 i want to go king c3
followed by b4
make some trade so that my king
will eventually be able to make inroads
all the way to b6 everything gets traded
off on the queen side i've got this very
active king on
b6 versus a passive light squared bishop
the chances of winning go really really
really high if white can get an active
king so it's all about uh white's king
it can't make a breakthrough if it can't
it's a win it's a win irene across his
game yesterday so this is so where when
she started getting her king and it was
just precisely right exactly even she
was up a pawn as well but if ana had a
greatly kept her king her rook from
cutting off the king would been very
tough for irena indeed so you're saying
that if you can get your king to c3 and
your beef and your b4 move in right and
be able to take with the king because of
course there might be some variations
where i get to put my king on c5 and
then you take you with the pawn isn't
leading to that type of infiltration
that you want right i'll always be able
to play knight v3 the other thing or
knight takes e6
right
well the other thing is that i do have
another
way of activating my king and that
way is actually right through the center
so for example in this position
although it's camouflage
my king could actually go to d4 to e5
and win the game like this now how about
if i try to trade knights on d7
precisely like you can that's exactly
the situation that i wanted to
show now you now with this retreat
knight to d knight to d4 to f3 you see
suddenly it's like an open fairway on a
green i thought you said i thought you
were going to say a fairy tale because
having that king on b4 and that knight
in e5 right so like the king comes to d4
maybe the king really wants to come to
e5 but we could put our king on d6 yeah
sure king to d6 but these are all kinds
of temporary uh things from uh
black's point of view this position i
would rate as
really close to a win i'm sure the
computer i'm sure the computer wouldn't
even uh consider that white has any
serious advantage but this one i'd like
i'd rate really really close to it
that's pretty much paralyzed so his
bishop is dead the knight could jump to
g5 and to create some more weaknesses
over here on black's king's side
and the ideal position of course would
be just to have something like this i'll
just put the ideal position for white on
the board just to give it kind of a
sense of positional overkill for a
moment
you're having a lot of fun with this
game exactly and i mean you know this is
like you know dominating king dominating
knight very bad bishop so what if we try
to play b5 ourselves offer i guess it's
hard to kind of work it in i'm trying i
would try to even
somewhere around these parts perhaps i
was trying to figure out a way to play
b5 so if you play b4 even though it's
positionally really ugly
you mean some situation like that b5 is
really a move that you really don't want
to play you put your you know you you
put a pawn on the same color as your
lights i was gonna try to put my bishop
on d7 instead so it won't be like quite
as ugly but the problem is it's hard to
put your [ __ ] in one d7 and play for b5
because then there's always going to be
knight takes d7 and b5 these types of
things so this is the kind of thing that
i was saying that white is aspiring to
probably he could also throw an h2h3
maurice moment again white actually did
play h3a in the game and this is move 24
of the game so they're still far away
from time control but of course uh
you know these this position neither of
them are
are likely to uh eat up all of their
time
and uh we've got maurice with some
thoughts on this battle which is going
to be very crucial for our u.s
championship
indeed jen it looks as though okobian is
definitely taking the safety first
approach yesterday he lost a big game
and in his opinion a bad game against
sam shanklin where he just got blistered
i mean the way he was beaten yesterday
left him in a great degree of shock you
could see it in his face after the game
after having had such a smooth path to
first place to get beaten like that
really must have hurt
deciding today play solid against kamsky
you know what kind of sleeping giant you
might awaken if you play incorrectly
it looks as though there is a
possibility of there being a six-way tie
for first not with this position we see
on the board now though but there is a
scenario that we have calculated that
shows that there's a possible six-way
tie for first first of all the head of
the pack you see ocobian and linderman
they would both have to lose today both
seemingly unlikely results
they would have to lose today one versus
kamsky and linderman versus moeller in
order for this scenario to go and then
draw each other tomorrow they're playing
each other in the last round so that's
going to be a big game kamsky would have
to win today and lose to friedel who is
currently
tied with him but he would have to lose
against
shanklin and beat kamsky for those
players all to be at six and a half are
you still following me folks that would
all have to fall into place in order to
get us
with those four players at six and a
half and then you'd have the shanklin
factor he's already defeated two of the
top players that is lenderman and
ocobian and he would simply have to win
his next two games against friedel and
against correa and then he would go to
six and a half as well
and
the rest
at the tail end well these are the hail
mary's guys because their chances of
doing this are very tricky they would
both have to they would all have to win
of course they can't all win because
they're playing each other as you see in
round 11 ownership is going to play
robson
and naraditsky right now is playing onus
chuck so only one of these could emerge
and get to six and a half in fact in any
scenario these three players
only one of them will get to six and a
half so we do have that kind of
mathematical possibility but the way
ocobian is playing this position now
that math is about to go out the window
or at least it's looking that way
because if a cobian wins and get if
kobien draws today and gets a six and a
half
even if lenderman managed to lose
one of them is going to have seven
points tomorrow because jacobian would
have six and a half playing someone with
six and any result will result in
someone at least having seven points and
likely locking up the championships guys
that's right this game is never going to
be a loss for version no i don't see
that in any scenario katakinsky did play
knight to d7 going for this trade so
what do you think his concept is against
your
your idea of switching the knight and
then putting the king on d4 and then i
don't e5 well exactly in this position
i'm still kind of double guessing the h3
so basically what kamsky is thinking is
that if he gets into this
you know good night bad bishop
uh type of situation is there time for
white for black to play b5 and b4 here
no then just white plays b4 and then
locks that down and then the position is
even more positionally bad well yes i
but i was thinking uh that uh another
scenario
is is just to play d5 d4
okay if i could get something like okay
so i'm not really too sure exactly how i
should you first want to move your
bishop
i i definitely don't want to allow
white's king just to come right around
the horn and you know put put the pawn
on d4
so let's say i could play d4 takes and
here
bishop b5 or yeah let's say bishop
knight c4 in the position yeah and then
just come up with the king so the idea
of activating
and doubling these pawns as a defensive
uh uh
effort because uh i do see
the good knight versus bat bishop ending
as losing i don't see
really good chances for ghada
uh of creating any fortress and god is
not
looking happy and put his hand in his
head
in a slower way though instead of going
for a knight c6 check
and uh we could try to keep more control
like instead of playing knight c6 check
immediately we could
we could take on d7 and then bring try
to bring our king over to uh
to c3 or play knight to f3 kind of
holding on to both squares well exactly
and i'm kind of double guessing this
move h3 once again so knight e5 here so
it's just a direct transposition right
i mean it's just the same position we
had a second ago
so if we
oh but i don't have to play 95 i'm
saying
in the other position my knight was on
c6 and it was attached i was here maybe
i can try to move my king around to c3
first okay sure so that i keep control
over your sacrificial ideas uh
maybe you have some other uh tactical
ideas here well tactics
strategic ideas but no
again so now king d2 you're going to
play bishop h5 and d4 anyway but maybe i
could have stopped it with g4 anyway
much to uh discuss here we've got our
grandmaster
ben feingold who's giving commentary
right next door at lester's he's a st
louis local and a popular
um host on the st louis chess club
youtube channel so we'll check in with
him about what's going on in the games
all right
thanks jen i'm with grandmaster ben
feingold giving commentary over lester's
ben welcome to the show thanks maria
it's great to be here ben anything so
far that has surprised you in this round
you are you're doing commentary with
grandmaster robert hess i should mention
as well right robert and i are doing
commentary occasionally some of the
players in the audience are stronger
than us so we get a little help
sometimes um basically i've been
disgusted today um and i think like you
and and jennifer and yester really have
it right when you retired from playing
competitive chess
because some of these guys got to retire
i mean i think yesterday uh
ownership after playing queen d5 check
should have stopped the clock and
retired and i think kamsky should have
retired after rook c4 yesterday and now
look at the way they play um yeah the
young guys are taking over i think today
is really showing that uh
komski ownership are finished and i mean
i i would be totally shocked if if
komski ties for first this tournament
and this just just isn't his tournament
he's not takamsky he used to be and a
lot of the games today aren't going the
way that i expected um we could start
with the comskey game sure playing the
opening just very timid very slow
playing a line that's not very good and
getting this worst position and then var
trading all the pieces off to make sure
he has zero losing chances but i think
he minimized his winning chances
somewhat i thought he had a huge
advantage and was really going to put
pressure on god with the huge time
advantage he has but var hates to lose
so much i think he's afraid okomsky he's
just making sure he doesn't lose do you
think that the game yesterday might have
really hurt his feelings and
like really not wanted to come today in
chat i mean really var was playing great
those four wins in a row weren't just
wins he was playing really well and when
he had some suspicious positions he was
defending really well yesterday just got
crushed i mean and you were talking
about it i mean
it really got crushed yesterday a nice
game from shankland unlike today where
shanklin's playing his usual terrible
self we'll get to that later uh yeah
kamsky hold back on your opinions by the
way no no
i'm i'm really upset today about the
play and usually
when the women have a rest day the men
are really fighting and playing a little
suspicious and we see few draws and lots
of active play so that's good for the
fans we don't have all the games to see
today but but this game here comes keep
playing really passively ocobian with a
big advantage gary said it on the air
white had a great position
and i think god is going to hold this i
don't think there's enough pieces left
on the board but i wouldn't want to be
black here just too passive indeed he
has to win too so to play so passively
when he has to win is very strange very
surprising maybe the the variation of
the dutch that was thrown at him he
didn't suspect it seemed like i moved
three or four he was already thinking a
long time when he knew he was going to
play the dodge so
and by the way uh ocobian did play this
way although it wasn't a blitz game
against a very strong player he played
knight c3 and bishop f4 um and he won
that game so he's done this before
okobian so shouldn't have been surprised
that he's done no i think he was more
surprised than he should have been he's
probably expecting a main line after
knight c3 he's like what so so good prep
by a cobian good position more time what
about linderman i mean lindeman doesn't
seem to be doing so badly now
lenderman's might pick to win the
tournament here's why after losing both
games i thought he's finished i thought
black against ownership and it's all
over mean ownership beat neridinsky nice
game here he's black and he's obviously
trying to win he's not like oh let's
play equal and try to draw komsky's
style he's trying to win the tournament
and i like the way he's playing he's got
a pretty easy pairing and moelner
considering considering he's not playing
a top player muller not having a good
tournament mullner is a good player but
lenderman's trying to win and he's
making the game unclear this game could
go either way and i think this is a
complicated game i think lenderman's
going to win i think london is going to
win this tournament he's playing really
well and got a lot of energy as a young
guy somehow my finger doesn't want to
work today
let's go to another game that's
important in the standings friedel
shanklin fredel has found himself back
in contention surprisingly he's the
lowest rated player in the tournament no
and friedel played great in the
beginning and lost in the first round of
lender bill from a good position totally
winning against niraditsky and then
ended up drawing and just playing well
throughout the tournament plus one plus
two and here he's better in this game
now what happened was black was fine and
then shanklin decided to play the worst
move he could find a5 okay a terrible
move stopping him from playing queen a5
losing a lot of tempe
weakening his position and and now i
like white this e takes f3 a decision to
try to win not play a boring draw
position but make it more double-edged
friedel's trying to win too i wouldn't
be surprised if friedel wins this
tournament because he's actually trying
to win the guys who are trying to win
the younger players who aren't playing
for a draw not playing solid those are
the guys i'm rooting for so i really
hope josh wins this game because he's
trying to win well you're you're like me
and i know like
playing for a draw at any cost uh you've
got to play chess ramirez robson though
what's up with this it's like crazy
sacrifice
is he just down upon for no reason uh
well there's a good reason he's getting
outplayed no actually but he sacrificed
the ball and he opened it typically he
didn't sacrifice it intentionally now i
had dinner last night with ray went to
one of my favorite thai restaurants and
i said look ray you got to stop doing
this one minute 10 seconds 5 seconds
time pressure
don't do that the rest of the tournament
just play fast and then i explain to him
lenderman's playing fast lenderman has
more points than you so play quickly
stop this time trouble nonsense and my
son was dealing with a spencer he's like
i never agree with my dad but i got to
agree with him here you got to speed up
right and this game race played very
quickly he's playing really well he's
basically a pawn up for nothing and we
expect him to win i don't know about
this sacrifice on the queen side once
you've played h4 i'm not sure you play
on both sides of the board like that
make weaknesses everywhere and rey is
playing quickly now the computer
obviously likes black's game blacks upon
up but i like the time ray has more time
now ray has a lot more time and ray just
moved look at this time situation raise
ahead and raise me to move right here
sitting here i can't believe it
that's pretty rare we've seen in the
championship ray's playing quickly and
ray's playing really well this game so i
expect black to win
pawn sacrifice was okay knight e1 i
didn't like that was too passive d5 was
a good move race playing incisively he's
playing quickly i think ray is going to
win this game indeed well thanks so much
for joining us grand master ben feingold
with lots of insights and a couple of
mild opinions guys
about the championships back to you
uh ben feingold ben comes ben is so easy
going he doesn't really come out and say
these guys are playing like idiots
they're jerks
like you the other day i
that
know
thai food go
go go those hot red peppers will do it
every time
josh lenderman versus the rest of the
field he is right in his angst that
why when you're the the national
championship is so close
why aren't you playing guns blazing and
got us seizing the defensive early and
just you know trying to
make a draw ooh i i don't like that i
think that ben has underestimated uh a
cobian's winning chances in this
position i think if he just does play
this move knight takes d7 bishop takes
d7 as we've been seeing uh maneuver his
pardon me maneuver his knight to the e5
squared go for this king uh walk to the
d4 square his chances of winning are
really
very very good now you were trying the
line with bishop ea just to unsettle
things a bit yeah and that's kind of a
a leap to nowhere but because white does
have this move g4 as you mentioned as we
were just about uh when we switched to
ben
but look at the position it's it's it's
it's you're not getting
you really wanted to get your little
tricky in with uh with d4 and try to get
me to capture the pawn but here it's not
quite happening because i'm just going
to move my king to cc3 before you do
that precisely and if you ever play b5
to try to play b4 then well white plays
b4 that's right again uh it makes the
king coming to d4 even more treacherous
because now it's also hitting the c5
square precisely very interesting you
put your pawn on b5 you kill your your
light squared bishop there's no bishop
a4 all the way down to d1 and who knows
where else you might go it's amazing how
quickly you intuited uh white's uh
massive chances here it takes a lot of
us
a little longer to see how
it might be
experience does matter and i do say that
uh the youth um it's you know the next
generations come and so forth and so on
um and and it seems to me like lenderman
uh has really basically said hey i'm the
guy of the future here you know pay
attention to to me
and uh his game
pardon me ben was saying that he felt
that the game
between lenderman and mac could go
either way i don't see that i i really
see it as uh going lenderman's way just
because i there's this move h4 uh just
feels uh
h4 and g3 and he feels
because uh he's got his queen and
rook lined up in that diagonal right so
we definitely like lenderman we're gonna
take a
big look at that when we come back from
break and we have another fisher puzzle
for you to solve so don't go anywhere
you never know who may show up in the us
chess championship we'll be back with
more from the 2014 event
hello welcome back to the 2014 us
championships and u.s women's
championships here in st louis the
capital of chess in america how many of
you guys correctly guessed the move
queen to b7
or guess i guess is the wrong word right
how many correct how many of you
correctly solved or found
maurice ashley explains why
yes jen this is a little bit of a trick
question right because i'm sure
everybody said well what's wrong with
queen a3 or queen before i'm just
winning
but fisher didn't just like to win he
liked to stomp okay so in this position
he did not play one of those checks he
started with a move that looks a little
dangerous as a matter of fact to move
queen to b7 allowing g takes h3 a disco
check on his king but he has a very
simple bishop to g3 now this kind of
move you think well you're also freezing
your bishop why would you take that out
of the game
what he realized was that this rook was
simply trapped where to put it
gelatro's d8 just want to show you what
happens if he put it on e8 instead well
then it's a simple trade
and then
it's all about
the rook
and queen and even this bishop entering
the party if the king goes over then
simply queen to c7 would be mate thanks
to that bishop and of course if the king
goes into f8
then simply
any mate on the back row will just pick
pick one all right so in this position
geller after seeing bishop to g3 played
the move rook to d8 and now fischer came
back with the move queen to b4 check and
this time it's much more powerful move
97 just leads to queen takes knight and
not only are you winning that night but
you're also picking up a rook in the
process
and trading off queens i might add
because if you go here you can't go back
in the corner because of rook
down with mate so it's all she wrote
keller decided to resign so queen b7 you
see a good move
look for a better one i think emmanuel
alaska said that back to you guys
thanks maurice and as did michael tall
kudos to those of you who found that and
uh we had some news going on in josh
ferdel's game all right maurice and i
were talking about over the break that
josh
seems to be in pretty good shape
the idea was to play the move
combination of h4 and queen to h6 and it
was very difficult for black to defend
all the weaknesses in the position for
instance the b5 pawn is under fire
and we're going to follow it up with h5
not so easy for you to bring your queen
to the defense because the b5 pawn is
also hanging so there's a number of
weaknesses here b5 g6 and that brooklyn
d8
can't move
forward to
to bolster g6 because of rookie 8 mating
right i'm just
i do like josh's attacking uh potential
on the king side knight
goes back to c5 trying
to
break the blockade there's some
possibilities a bishop takes b5 here
that could come into play as well with
the idea of f6 in this particular
position
knight e6 fails to rook takes e6 and
you've got the uh ready to go checkmate
that uh
takes b5 you don't you're not forced to
capture you can just keep going right i
get counter play with this move but it's
still uh
it's still looking like good attacking
uh potential here for white white could
continue
uh with um
keep going with i'll probably h5
immediately
i like walter brown's immediately h5
immediately d2 counter play for sure
i have to stop this pawn for the moment
but now this pawn is hanging
still uh a lot of it's just not taboo
anymore though because 96 is not covered
oh you can take maybe
i may be setting up for
for a different uh
type of checkmate in this case and if i
retake you're going to snag my rook on
d8 with a with a check well not
necessarily because you've got
the f8 square here but definitely
white for choice in
this game but now we only got our queen
and we won more than a per well let's
just say the championship might hang in
the balance between a win and draw so
and so knight b3 has been played i
thought we saw some other moves from the
webcam there for a moment queen h6 is
not white's only other choice another
choice jen i
kind of like
posting up with the queen on g5 as well
just to keep that rook under uh
guard for a moment if i don't put my
bishop on pre if i just step back with
my bishop
and keep pounding on this g6 against
this g6 pawn i don't think the d2 pawn
is running any
any further i've got i've got my rook
and my queen ready to go and this bishop
actually might sneak out on this
diagonal against black's king so
definitely sam shanklin under a lot of
pressure
in this key game for our tournament
standings as well that's right because
if josh rodell is to win this game he's
going to leave to six and a half points
of course black against gotta camping no
easy order but
i mean hey opportunity knocks you need
to
may pull off one of the best one of the
greatest successes of this chess career
that's right and go josh
and speaking of god akamsky by the way i
really didn't like the way
he played the position
shocking ocobian as we've
been witnessing throughout this whole
game
has um
been playing it ultra ultra ultra safety
and
to continue playing ultra safety would
have meant trading knights
surprisingly enough accobian said no i
i'll allow knights to stay on the board
and not just play a pure
ending
versus a bad bishop
was this a wise decision by him we will
find out but i do like
once again this rather
straightforward idea of bringing white's
king
into an active aggressive position
and godda still
has is going to have a real real hard
time in my opinion uh saving this game
um it's a tough
position for him with this last move
knight c5 if he has some chances to get
counter play perhaps with the knight b3
and d4 idea that you were talking about
earlier right or knight a4 at the right
moment so
maybe something like king e1 just so
that in case of a knight a4 b3 i'm not
given i'm not allowing you to move the
knight with a check
against my king so if your knight comes
in it may be a suicide mission this
knight may not get out
from white's camp for example after
knight d4
followed by well do i want to yeah maybe
i do want to play a4 and king d2 this
knight could find itself stranded on c3
so not a pleasant
situation that's right and your your
idea from before doesn't work it he is
well here because
if instead of knight a4 you play knight
b3 with the idea of the sacrifice on d4
well
now there's also a knight c6 check in
the position so i think you're a little
bit too late for instance just kind of
one now right can't do d4 now because of
knight c6 jack
with a nice fork and picking up the pawn
for free and if you wait for a move and
try to play king d6 to get out of that
check well
then king c2 is too fast yeah you're
giving the knight the boot well i mean i
suppose there's a4 but
and that's the thing yeah we are putting
a pawn on a light square right you're
making a very uh nice target over here
on the queen side and we it's it's
clearly visible that with moves like
knight d4 and king knight d4 and king b4
uh white's all over
uh the position here uh so we can expect
ghada to find the best defenses in this
game yes he's you know he's exceptional
with his back to the wall he really does
find the resources but i got to tell you
this is not a pleasant position for our
defending champion indeed no and in our
most exciting game in the round today
for both the standings and perhaps the
explosive possibilities we've got
mackenzie moellner against alexander
lenderman oh my
maurice has more in that game
indeed we have been waiting to see this
game sharpen up and usually that happens
when pawns are offered on exchange
because lines open pieces get more
active possibilities begin to percolate
in those kind of situations we see this
happen here in this position after this
queen trade a rook trade excuse me you
had a situation where you felt like
nothing much was going on necessarily
the only open file is the d line you
might have suspected a move like rook d8
like in the other games but lenderman
said i'm not interested in playing chess
like that i have a four to three
majority on this side that is four pawns
to three that's his side of the board so
no reason to compete for the d file let
me play the move rook to e8 to start let
me deal with chess on this side of the
board and try to dominate here his
opponent played the move knight to e1
and now he played the very interesting
b5 preventing any queen trade with queen
to c4 that was in the position so
clearly lindemann is trying to keep the
game alive with interesting
possibilities he doesn't want to see any
end games he wants to see if he can win
in the middle game somehow or at least
milk as many possibilities from the
middle game before jumping into an
advantageous ending well his opponent
decided well let me see if i could take
advantage of that last move c4
and instead in this position we see the
move e4
was played now
let me say and then maybe i'm wrong
let's go back to
uh this position here this was the game
guys c4 was played e4 the the computer
suggested an amazing possibility here
the move bishop to g4 which
looks
like it's easily answered by this move
f3
but now the move e4
bizarre computer idea the point being
after takes then the move queen takes
with check now your queen can't block
because the bishop is hanging and if the
knight were to block
then knight takes on g4 and suddenly
there are all these terrific threats on
the bishop and
here on h2 possible mating ideas it
looks as though linderman might have
missed a win in this moment the move
c4 could have been met by bishop to g4
f3 looks of course knight f3 is met by
e4 f3 looks logical and then suddenly
this move e4 attacking his pawn again
getting this pressure on this diagonal
exploiting the wii king so guys it seems
as though lindemann did miss a win we
can analyze this a little bit more of
the move king h1 is also met by knight
takes g4 and there's monster threats on
this bishop this pawn is hanging with
check lenderman
missed a win now that move i have to say
the move bishop g4 e4
came out of the blue i absolutely didn't
see the idea
of course these computers are so beasty
it's not an easy move to spot yaz but
lenderman missed his chance to coast
almost in these u.s championships seven
points would be huge for him going into
the last round he's still working hard
on his position but he did miss what
seems to have been a winning line guys
yeah that's pretty interesting i wanna i
wouldn't be surprised if it did uh
strike his fancy and then he wasn't
totally sure about the complications
bishop g4 f3 e4 perhaps uh
he is it possible that he missed maybe
what
the variation after bishop to f4
it seems that maybe there's like a takes
on f3 there
right well for sure the queen on c7
uh standing in wait uh
for that opportunity of ambushing
snagging upon on g3 so after b5 c4 for
sure this move bishop g4 f3 e4 was not
missed by lenderman he probably had a
mistaken judgment that maybe after
bishop f4 so now instead of
something like just take a pawn i think
just takes an f3 i think this in-between
move seems pretty strong because
now after yeah bishop takes c7 you have
pawn takes e2 picking and you end up up
a pawn precisely knight takes f3 but
this is just
fantastic for black i mean white's king
is weak bishop so you fight track is
probably just winning so i'm i'm with
maurice 100
i see the position after e4
e5 e4 in conjunction with bishop g4 is
simply snap crackle pop that's game over
wow very uh
but let's see what has happened so
instead he played e4 obviously
threatened me bishop to g4 whoops i got
the wrong position i play i beg your
pardon and he played for threatening
a
function of playing quickly remember he
tries to play practically and quickly so
he might not even look very deeply
muller is only eight minutes left on the
clock so he's probably thinking let me
just keep playing fast forget about
concrete variations that might have cost
him right now the move c4 probably
didn't look that bad to him so he just
played a nice positional move but he
should have found the tactics or looked
at the tactics in that position he's
simply unaware probably that he missed
that variation i don't know it seems so
it's so up the alley of the position and
i kind of agree with the ass that maybe
he hallucinated bishop f4 takes on f3 or
something something because
that that is
it has a logical flow having said that i
find out that lenderman is basically
saying it looks pretty high it really
does i mean with my move e4 i've got i'm
setting up for the skewer against the
rook
mac moved his queen out of that skier
and uh
b
5b4 came basically saying hey look your
pieces are a little bit
silly over here on the queen side
c4c5 and lennemann said well the only
thing defending that pawn uh your queen
and bishop let me eliminate the bishop
on e3 let me go for knight takes e3
followed by bishop take c5 and i'll be
winning anyway so maybe in lenderman's
mind he thinks he's just simply cruising
and life
is good and getting better and better so
maybe he thought that this was
a win without any complications whereas
somehow in the line with e4 there were
some complications which maurice has
shown the complications aren't there
black is just stone cold winning well
you might have thought there were a few
yeah wow so this was looking really
lovely for lenderman now let's take a
look over at the us women's chess
championship uh of course it is a rest
day so you just see empty boards here
and women's chess championship hall
and tomorrow we are going to see some
key matchups though in their final round
both tournaments conclude tomorrow of
course unless there is a play-off arena
crushing others ponsky both tied at the
top
um after irena
beat her yesterday for that chance to
catch up to the main rival
and tomorrow um irena is actually going
to be playing against
victoria me with the black pieces
and zatonski's going to be playing
against nemkova with the white bases so
nitowsky playing the player with the
better score but with white crush
playing me who's lost a lot of
opportunities but uh seems to be playing
pretty solidly in a lot of games so i
think that there's definitely a chance
that both of them win and we'll see
another historic and thrilling uh
crushed tonsky playoffs stay tuned guys
for that absolutely
and again i just brought up the game
between
shanklin and
josh
and let's just go back a few moves
because it appears to to my eyes at
least
that
after the move queen
f4
sam was really worried about what was
happening over here
against his king on the king's side he
played the defensive move queen f6 and
josh went queen c7 which is really nice
move i like this move very much both
offense and defense not only is a queen
posting up nicely on the seventh rank
but it's basically containing black's
knight so there's no idea exactly so
there's no knight c5 breaking the
blockade and josh is looking really good
and sam under severe pressure here
sam definitely does not want to capture
this pawn which would uh weaken
his king's position and allow a
possibility just overcoming the e7 and
disconnecting the the queen and the rook
and attacking f7
right it looks pretty ugly well and
exactly that's the threat that white has
in the position is this move rook e7
and there's no connection between
black's pieces queen and rook i think
sam played king f8 yes he did to stop
that
powerful threat and now nice ideas of
rook over
something like takes and rook up and
rook over um
playing against that pawn on f7 josh
thinking i thought i saw him reaching a
moment there just to be sure after takes
takes
and putting this position on the board
with a very obvious threat
of rook f4 and rook takes f7 check or
bishop takes g6
check types of ideas last but not least
don't forget there's a pawn on b5
hanging so in case of
sometimes mass trades uh there might
just simply be a bishop takes b5 and a
winning end game uh as well for white if
we how about if queen d6 queen d6 just
trying to bail out tactically i'm gonna
lose a pawn in the end of the variation
if i take and take but probably i
i think i want to keep queens
uh where can i move my queen
i'm way over here on a7 the thing is i'm
ready to play knight c5 again right but
you still have this workout four move
right and now how does it look if i go
for the sacrifice line with the
ah queen takes f4 and knight takes d3
uh giving up the queen
uh probably you didn't need to have to
jump into that this still looks
pretty good for white but a moment ago
no reason to panic yet
you could have played rook d7 just
defending f7 and in case of a check on
the back ring king g7 and black's king
is okay so i didn't play it very well
with my rook up and over
i'll have to come up with something a
little bit better because you don't call
it a rover it didn't end up working i
suppose yeah a rover so it's nice that
if we do take the pawn um immediately
that uh that prevents us from playing uh
and so after takes in b5 right or take
some maybe we could take we might want
to take g6 first just so you don't have
queen tanks f5 okay we'll we'll
so we take take
we are allowing the d-pawn to run for a
moment but let's just
uh calculate the line it doesn't seem to
me
that with this bishop on a4 helping
protect the d1 square
that the pawn's going that far
meanwhile if you would drive the queen
d6 attack jack uh the queen d6 there
my point is that i have the move
work to e8 jack which i did not have
before oh that's always a very nice
tactic
uh check
the rook is tied anchored to the
protection of the queen so if you trade
take my rook i'll take your queen if you
move your king i'll take your rook so
rookie 8 would be a winner
and we've got some news uh so looking
hot for josh riddell and meanwhile we
have some news from monar lender man
maurice what's going on
well jen i'm just so fascinated by the
position i'm really in shock at how
easily weiss position would have
collapsed in the game between molnor and
lindeman if lindemann had found that
move look at some of these variations
they are nasty i mean incredible lines
the move bishop to g4 simply winning
kerplunk ker splat all the batman words
that's what would have happened here
because the move f3
e4 double exclamation mark all the way
down i think
even if lenderman saw this move the
variations are not completely obvious to
calculate it's not even that the move
bishop f4 would have been so hard guys
because the diagonal is going to open to
the king and the queen could always
sidestep that move but it's the other
lines that are so complicated let me
just start with the move you suggested
bishop to f4 this variation could have
been met by a few moves but bishop to c5
looks like the best one now the king has
to be very careful because this rook is
eyeballing that queen remember that rook
move on e8 avoiding the open file that
just shows grandmaster level great move
he may not have seen the tactics but he
understood rook on the same line as a
queen anything could happen and here it
would where could the king go it has to
hide from any discovered checks so king
h1 looks like the safest bet but now
just simple e takes f3
you might say well why is this any good
well for starters if you take the rook
then simply knight takes and after
bishop takes queen looks like you're up
but suddenly f
two
bishops attacking rook pawn's attacking
knight pawn's threatening to become a
queen look out you have no way to deal
with all these threats so this move this
position is dead lost another
possibility here
after e takes f3 bishop takes c7 right
away instead of the kamikaze moves let's
just take but that doesn't help he just
plays rook takes queen and you just have
to compare the position what's his pawn
doing on f3 i mean the position is
busted f2 is coming for starters and if
this knight were to move away let's say
to the d3 square then simply bishop to
d4
lenderman would understand he's
completely winning here there's a pawn
sitting here in white's throat this
bishop is going to come to h3 there's
made threats dominant everywhere but
these are not even the funky lines the
lines that he had to consider after f3
and e4 come with the move f takes g4
now a check
and the most natural move is knight g2
and this line is the line he would have
to have analyzed and said what exactly
am i threatening here am i in fact
winning completely the threat seems to
be check and check
but the bishop can block so this might
have been something he said i'm not sure
that you know at night on g2 a night in
front of a king we know protects a king
really well you can dance around the
checks of a queen but not if a night
another night on the other side is
helping out and here this check is going
to come so let's just analyze a few
variations if you start by ignoring what
black is doing then watch this check the
king moves then queen h1 check then the
bishop goes back to g1 this is the
position we were looking at but now
comes the move bishop to c5
and the added piece in the game
simply wins there's nothing to do about
this attack on the bishop you can't
block with your knight because the
simple capture and your bishop is pinned
so that would be losing let's look at
another line here
rook d5 instead right before here to
deal with the upcoming threat of bishop
to c5 you play this move but now look at
this sweet line queen check the attack
still rolls on queen h1 check and after
this move bishop back to g1 now knight
h2
check king has to stay on this bishop it
wants to go here and now the move
knight f3 wins for starters but i like
another move the move e3 check look at
this one if you take with the king your
bishop is hanging if you take with the
queen
knight g4 is sweet nice little fork
and after e3 check if you take with the
knight
you have to scratch your head at this
bizarre checkmate
plenty of attacking lines he would have
had to really study the position deeply
to realize that he was completely
winning bishop g4
followed by e4 was totally totally
winning in the game no chances at all
for his opponent and it just slipped by
the night
i'm sure he's completely unaware of what
happened guys let's take a look at the
game as it is thanks maurice because
we've got uh some a lot of excitement
here is mona has only five minutes in
the clock and it seems the position's
actually kind of blowing up wow we got
the position on the board yeah queen c4
has just been played and
was played was bishop e6 was played
because queen c4
uh um
set up a battery with this bishop on b3
to play queen takes f7 check and start
taking black's pieces with check right
knight takes e3 would allow queen takes
f7 and then after king h7 you have queen
takes rook and bishop yeah oh that's
actually a pattern that everybody should
know this should be in your
quiver of weapons this this particular
pattern it's a real pretty one if you go
queen g8 check all you do is allow the
king to escape but you first play bishop
check
repositioning the bishop to cover the g6
square and you should all know this
checkmating pattern it's an absolute it
comes out time and time again very
similar to one that you love to show
earlier where you had to maneuver that
bishop to g6 and do the queen eight
seven queen
remember
bishop takes h7 check bishop g6 so
um dealt with that with bishop e6 and
now after queen takes e4 he played
knight takes c3
and now
queen takes c3 appears in the board of
course he can't take with the f pawn
because the g3 pawn hangs
and now takes e3 has been played takes
e3 but now bishop takes c5 how sweet it
is those bishops are just lovely aren't
they i mean uh there is a an ambush
against the g3 pawn so he's gonna have
to he's gonna have to keep an eye on the
g3 pawn otherwise queen takes g3 check
is in the position exactly so we've got
two choices it seems queen f3
this kind of like a natural move now in
this position your first thought might
be uh to trade bishops but uh but after
bishop takes b3 a takes b3 well it's an
ending
you might want to think about this b8 to
b7 yeah maybe better
the bishop and and uh
thank the luck he stars that there's a
lot of weaknesses over here against
white's king so and very tough for you
to increase the pressure on that f7
point we could try playing something
like if we try a cheapo like rook c1
trying to go for um rook takes c5
well
now
uh position's actually pretty
interesting because uh bishop takes f2
um doesn't doesn't really necessarily
lead to anything because after king
takes f2 queen c1 again f7 is hanging
with jack
exactly in that line what about knight
to d3 and knight to d3 uh instead of
rook c1 that looks
looks safer say safe er attacking the
bishop probably provoking the bishop to
to come back just to keep it to tsuji
against the knight on d3
and then rook c1 in that position maybe
yeah it's all just kind of temporary
because i think it's the two bishops the
two b's that black is playing for i mean
white is doing his best
not here though rookie one in this
position rookie one trading no trade i'm
going to sacrifice oh very good
uh i just have to find a good square for
my queen queen a7 i'm sorry we should
show that line because we're talking as
though everybody's following us okay
sure
d6 gotcha gotcha uh bishop to d6 maurice
had a very nice uh cheapo in the
position so after rook e1 attacking the
queen if the queen won't go to d7
maurice's point was that hey
check
and
lucky lucky i get the rook
there's there's no recapturing because
of the pin
nice tactic
definitely
uh let me just see the current position
because that game really has heated up
and we do we have an f3 on the board and
we do have queen f3 on the board the
line we're looking at
maybe
mac
is happy to get this slightly worse
position
with the 2b
playing against the two b's because at
least his king is not getting checkmated
in in that awful way that maurice was
showing us if white can just simply get
his knight back
into the game back in the battle with
knight d3 good chances still of
equalizing and are the times correct
four minutes to 18
what i'm seeing on yes
we got four minutes to 18 that's exactly
right yeah and uh of course linderman
now won't move after queen to f3 right
okay so
may well clearly uh alex has missed a
golden opportunity there earlier still
uh
having some pull but certainly not the
win
that he would have liked what a sweet
way to win that would have been
i'm i'm pulling up our game uh on our
top board
um
it seems that white has done
both both breaks uh covene has made both
breaks on the queen side he's played b4
and on the king side he's played g4
let's see how he usually wanted to get
your king on
d4 before i did any of this stuff
okay let's see how it did go
i would have traded knights by the way
and gotten a pure knight ending he went
b4 right away hmm
i really thought
that uh
it made more sense to try to activate
the king first he
var b4 right away takes takes
knight b7 g4 takes takes
knight d6
knight d4
h6 still a very
pleasant uh
advantage for var how is he going to win
this one though this is going to be
tough well i wonder if he was worried
about king c3d maybe there was just like
a knight a4 check trying to keep the
king at bay and here similarly king c3
knight b5 check kind of lead keeping us
from being able to blockade that square
okay well hmm
uh first of all after king c3 no i'm not
i was talking about if
you hadn't played knight to d4
i moved a moment ago yeah if you pl if
you try to just play king c3 here it's
nice that the b5 check
kind of keeps that king at bay well the
problem what var has done is he's
basically he's locked up the queen side
when i was trying to recapture on b4
with hit with the king to keep it fluid
and to be able to play a4a5 so gada has
been gifted
a number of defensive options i don't
think i would have allowed him h7h6 now
i think that
what var needs to do to activate his
king
is to go all the way over here to h4 so
that he may be able to play
g4 g5 one day but i think goddess
chances of making a draw have increased
a great deal over from where he was so
some and you're getting the kingdom and
it hasn't seemed like var has made any
progress in that area that's pretty so
it's not about kind of making an extra
pawn weakness or getting your pawns in
slightly better squares we really must
get the king into play well exactly and
right now on d2 it's not active enough
to
uh push
the game
into a victory column
and let's see what he did play it looked
like he moved tonight yeah he made a
retreating move so he has played kingy
too by the way
if i the players are definitely speeding
up so king e2 var is recognizing that uh
if anything his king's got to come over
here to the king side
and now king f6 was played by ghada and
now that's where what we saw on the
webcam version playing knight on d to f3
after king f6 and now gotta playing
g5 perhaps uh var was worried would be
even stronger if his knight hadn't
retreated back to f3 here
and this trade upon
did he trade already no no no no no no
no no no now it's var and move but he
actually has less than three minutes so
even though there's only six moves to
make and we're close to time control
he's still going to have a
some pressure with that clock ticking
away
meanwhile and ramirez robson a game that
seemed exciting earlier maurice has an
update for us
yesterday remember when grandmaster
feingold was here he said
he told ray robinson yesterday play fast
and don't get into time pressure well
it's not so easy to cure the disease of
poor time management because now we're
looking at this position and robson
after having a huge
solid advantage let's call it on the
clock
he's now down to three minutes and he's
got to make 13 moves even with the
increment and he has furthered away his
advantage in the game so that time
management disease so many players we've
seen over the years had have it
the most infamous one being alexander
ivanov who played in these championships
for many years
before getting a bit older now but man
playing him was always a circus almost
watching how much time pressure he would
get into and then if you ever fell into
the belief that you could blitz him in
time pressure boy he would show you
something different he'd play so quickly
in time pressure not just quickly but
strong moves as well but ray does not
want this to be a habit that chases him
throughout his career he's going to have
to solve it because he went from having
a good position here to no real
advantage anymore
just a slight a smidgen of advantage
that he's trying to keep and also not
blunder somehow and mess up his game
shifting to another game there is some
conservative play that's happening on
other boards as well
that
is actually at the leaderboard and fidel
josh friedel has now managed to get
himself into a worse position before he
was doing so well we were really
enjoying this position for him licking
licking our chops thinking about all the
possibilities queen 86 was actually the
most direct and powerful move but
instead he played the move h4 also not a
bad move knight to b3 queen f4 a little
conservative queen to f6 and then he
started losing the threat a little bit
he played the move queen to c7 and
here's where everything got interesting
after the move king f8 he could have
snapped this pawn but again we realized
this d-pawn
really produces complications
but instead and he could also just play
it solidly but instead he chose to trade
here and then here was the critical
moment safety first not allowing a
knight to go to d2 he played the move
rook to d1 and this changed the entire
complexion of the game he had a line
here i'm not going to say he should have
seen it but a very consistent move would
have been the move h5
the point being that after a knight to
d2 threatening knight of three check
rook up a check king here and now pawn
takes pawn in this position could be met
by queen to c5 picking back up his pawn
he might have analyzed this whole
variation and thought after queen takes
rook to h8
and he can't touch the knight because of
suddenly rook down to h2 check and he's
losing his queen for the two pieces with
a lost position by the way he might
somehow dream of a fortress but this is
a pretty bad looking position
so he might have looked at all this and
gotten to that moment and said whoa whoa
i'm not going into that line and backed
up but he was still okay he could have
sorry i have to rook to h8 he could have
just simply played a check
to get out of the position and
then just play another check if he wants
to then just put the queen right here
the point is now his queen is in the way
he's threatening to take the knight
queens come off
but even that position he'd have to see
all the way down and realize that this
position was good for him not at all
easy
a task to do
instead he played the move rook to d1
safety first
and sam pounced with rook to d5 covering
all his weaknesses now and suddenly this
knight is looking a lot better than it
did before queen to b7 queen to e5
centralizing his pieces and who do you
like here you've got to like black it
looks like white's the one on the
defensive no not any longer in control
of the e file no real attack to speak of
and now he played the move queen to a7
and sam's time pressure a little bit not
that much time pressure four moves to
make in nine ten minutes and block this
looks fine here black is okay so it
looks as though
all the players at the top are feeling
the pressure in this penultimate round
of the championships and not playing
super aggressive yes looks like they're
playing it real close to the vest guys
lots of slippage in from advance
advantageous positions to be sure
uh friedel not the only one a kobe in
another and it looks like lenderman as
well so all of our leaders faltering a
little as they're getting closer and
closer to their claim on the national
title now instinctively if we go to that
monar lenderman game you wanted to keep
two bishops on the board i did right
the two chavos
we called them rabbis
in the pacific northwest the two right
yes all right so um
king takes you i'm sorry um
when you were talking about playing
bishop c8 and rerouting the bishop to b7
enjoying to keep the two bishops instead
lenderman perhaps assessed that that
wasn't going to be quick enough and he
traded on b3 immediately okay bishop
takes b3 white wanted to keep control
over the e2 square didn't want to allow
queen takes rookie two
and so recaptured with the pawn and now
he played the move bishop to f8 perhaps
anticipating that white could black
could play rooks you want at the right
moment and embarrass although at the
moment it was of course held down by the
bishop takes off to tactic
after knight d3 it would have been
possible right so bishop f8 and now
white played king dj too
so is to improve the position of the
king and now black has played a5 and
where were all those tactics we used to
have yeah it's not there anymore are
there well there's only one problem for
white in the position obviously is the
knight on e1
all white really needs to do is find a
good square c4 is the most obviously the
most ideal square uh for the knight
because it'd be protected by the pawn he
hit the paw hit the pawn on a5 well
white did play queen d3 and that does
open the f3 square for the knight to
relocate via d2 or
e5 perhaps
i no longer see alex as winning this
position or even being
significantly better the only reason
that alex might be better is if he could
route his bishop to the h8 a1 diagonal
and
lock in on this pawn on b2 his idea of
bishop f8 may have been precise to do
precisely that
with the move g7 g6
uh attempting to fianchetto the bishop
and um
target the pawn on v2 but otherwise
this looks pretty balanced to me and i
don't like obviously these dark these
pawns on the queen side being under
right so you basically think the
potential of the knight landing on c4
and the double pawns really pretty much
balance each other out exactly exactly
so i see this game is pretty much going
to a draw if that you have to be careful
to say that at the championship i i
totally agree that it's looking really
balanced and um you thought that version
ocobian faltered a little bit as well
not making the most of his advantage so
not just a little bit i think a lot of
it i think oh and now we're looking at
the position now i've got it and i think
it's just closing into a draw now
with actually cutting off his ability to
bring his king into the game this move
g5 exactly you wanted to try to get him
by h4 that's no longer possible right
and no longer possible to get in via d4
either because knight b5 check's always
going to be in the position just to show
our
so we just have to make a move here for
black first of all i guess we could
start maybe with just the move knight b5
and there's no king c3 and if we just go
back and forth king c3 by the way king
d4 is not a threat that would work into
checkmate and one would be great
yeah get out of wins right ah how can
you at least put that variation on him
sure we sure will so uh
wait but we need to find a move for
white here
yeah we need to find a move for black
that allows it yeah well just put just
play bishop d7 or a4 bishop a4 bishop a4
thank you so we just found a square so
that we can show that
oopsy daisy
uh checkmate you finally got your king
into the game yes
yes i was trying to do that but uh
not at the cost of a checkmate
um
so you're you're you're believe who do
you think is more likely to win version
or lenderman
well i see
this game as really now drawn like i
don't think there's really too much to
play for
for either side and in the lenderman
game
so you would say lenderman then
yeah
if i had a chinese weird things might
happen but you know
sometimes when you're playing uh
with the night
weird things can happen the night might
end up on some spectacular square like
say
you know you played g6 h5
you've provoked your opponent to play g5
the knight might end up spectacularly
well on the f5 square
so um
i'm going to say a draw in both games
but
letterman better be careful that he
doesn't overpress
and by the way one other
thing i should note there is the
possibility of goddakamsky playing the
move d5 d4 and that might um
ah no i beg i
excuse myself it does give up the c4
square now this game is heading for a
draw for sure uh
and i think uh
we're going to see two players tied
going into
the last round
well let's read through the results
let's uh
take a quick break and we'll be back for
more from the 2014 u.s chess
championships which looks like it's
going to be setting us up for quite an
interesting final round
huge
so
tourette's
hello and welcome back to the 2014 u.s
chess championships here in st louis how
many of you found the answer to that
puzzle we've got maurice for all the
details
well we know jen that some of these
puzzles
are
pretty dominating positions on the part
of bobby fischer and he had different
ways to win the the cleanest the crispy
creamiest way actually to win this
position was bishop takes on c5 removing
this knight as a defender so that he
could do the follow-up move after rook
takes on c5 or anything takes on d5 for
that matter the sacrifices the move you
really needed to see rook takes on e6
with check and now the rook is skewering
the king and queen so you have to take
with something but no matter what you
capture back with pawn or king then
queen to f6 would be checkmate and so
his opponent after bishop c5 uh just was
simply busted typical dominating
performance from bobby fischer guys
well meanwhile we do have our first
official result of the round the game
version of kobe and gotta kempsky was a
draw and of course that has massive
implications for the us chess
championship farouz nacobian is now
going into the final round at half point
ahead of godikamsky and he'll be playing
alexander lenterman who if he draws
today
will also be in the lead by half a point
so if that game is decisive we'll have a
u.s champion exactly but if we don't
then we'll have a playoff
potential for a three-person playoff
depending upon how josh uh fares with uh
sam shanklin as well right so if the
game is a draw we'll definitely have at
least a two-way play-off and maybe we'll
get donna into the mix but exactly hey
things don't look so great for josh
in fact they've gotten a little bit
worse
a lot worse
okay okay
sam first you mentioned you like josh we
like josh's position like 10 moves ago
tremendously right and then you thought
he was losing the threat and maybe worse
but now it looks like sam shanklin has
managed to snap up a pawn right before
time control queen takes uh we'll see
basically what happened is
um that josh i think underestimated his
chances he was trying to
make a blockade against the d-pawn he
saw an opportunity i guess he felt he
had this opportunity to capture on b5
but the move d3 was actually simply
excellent for black and after h5 queen
takes b2 discovered attack against the
not a discovered attack a direct attack
against the bishop the bishop can't drop
back rook d4 there's an issue against
queen and bishop so
um
on the webcam that uh
sam's looking a little nervous that is
by the way because he hasn't yet made
his 40th move he does have over two
minutes but the clock is still ticking
away from him after he makes this move
we expect him to be more relaxed well
just let's see what he can do here first
of all a very uh direct simple move
might be moved like queen e2 or pardon
me
sorry mouselip or even queen c2
attacking the rook and look at this the
rook on
on
d5 is perfectly positioned to snap up
this pawn over here on h5 as well so
sam
the spoiler
shanklin is about i think to spoil yet
another
player's event
this time josh friedel
i might add guys by the way uh that in
that case in the case of the draw that
happened with a cobian and komski anyone
sitting on four and a half right now has
been mathematically eliminated from the
tournament because someone will get to
seven no matter what happens in the game
between lindemann uh and mullner
because a version of cobian is on six
and a half points
someone will get to seven even if
lindenman were to lose and he had six
points to ocobe in six and a half one of
those two players just by virtue of the
mathematics
a draw or a win by someone will get at
least seven points so all the four and a
half's they're out of the tournament now
uh naredinsky um robson
onishchuk and even sam shanklin with a
win today he will get to five and a half
but it will not matter he will not be
able to catch the leaders all of those
guys their dreams of winning the u.s
championship concluded this round right
we have seen a move by the way queen b3
by sam shanklin neither the queen c2 or
the queen e2 which just snaps upon over
on h5 but rather
i do believe sam has played the move
queen b3 inviting white to josh to make
a queen trait and
black sam shanklin has probably
calculated some variation where
one of these pawns is about to promote
well sure the uh the pawn could go to d2
and then the knight could maneuver to c3
exactly
very undesirable
square for the rock exactly
exactly
and uh also still the spawn on h5 is
hanging so sam looking very good having
made the time control he'll get
his bonus time now and
josh is probably going to have to sit
there and suffer
uh and say
why did i blow this wasn't it
wasn't i doing very well let me go to
the other uh find a way that's out there
yes exactly
let me go to our other game between our
co-leader
uh alex
uh lenderman having black queens have
come off the b2 pawn has been eliminated
but so is the a5 pawn
i think
well i think it's going to be a draw but
if i had
to choose a color i think uh the knight
in this position because the pawn is on
a dark square
no it's just a draw it's just a draw i
was just i was having some fantasy that
white might be able to do something uh
to have better chances how did this
happen we'll go back to uh this
situation and the following moves were
all played
instead of fianchettoing as bishop by
the way
landerman felt it was better just to
bring his bishop back out into the game
queen five bishop here rogue d5 very
nice going after the a5 pawn
queen c2 takes takes and this is how
they've achieved the position on the
board so a very balanced uh game now
uh lenderman having missed a forced win
a beautiful forced win
that maurice pointed out and
um
just setting us up for once again the
final round
uh
tomorrow well the interesting thing is
that we kind of expected for dell to
draw or win this game earlier in the
game but now and so he'd have a fighting
chance against gotta now if he loses
this game against gada he'll basically
be playing the role of spoiler he'll no
longer actually have chance to win the
championship exactly because he'll only
have five and a half points and gata
meanwhile would be having to play all
out for the win and josh
just defending for
rating points prestige final placement
of course the prize dip money is
differentiated and never spot
but a lot different than the excitement
we might expect if he also had to play
for the win exactly for first place
exactly that being said i think
lenderman
and akobian in their game they are both
going to be very aware of the fact that
kamsky can catch up exactly and because
of that they are not i mean definitely
no short draw 100 percent first of all
it's against the roles but i don't even
think we'll see a position where it's um
timid i think both players will be
playing very actively trying to avoid
the potential of a three-way play-off
which actually would be pretty likely
well again god has got to be very happy
to be in the situation he has been in
our defending champion
has not been in his best form and today
he was fortunate to get the draw but he
is here in our studio to share
his ups and downs
of this round that's right
godda kamsky he's with maurice ashley
and his chances for winning the u.s
championship
still very real playing the white pieces
against josh riddell in the last round
thanks jen i am with grand master and
four-time
champion u.s champion godakomski got it
welcome to the show
this game it looks like you had no
chances from the beginning to win you
were always a little bit worse
were you happy with well i i guess i'm
going to ask that question i'm sure you
weren't happy with the way the opening
went what went wrong
well um
to be really honest i completely messed
up my move order on the second move and
um i was preparing some other line and
then i remembered this line
which was shown to me by my second uh
vulcan like many years ago
and
then
rajan played this new idea of taking on
c5
and
92 with the idea of c4 opening up the
squares and i
i realized my position was really
unpleasant
so
i don't know then i just started to
think and uh came up some defensive
moves but overall white was always
better
i think that he managed
he shouldn't have allowed me to play a5
because after e5
um
white can no longer make progress on the
queen side did you think it was the
correct direction for him to go and
trade off all the pieces to get to this
end game or should he have played more
activity we just looked a little bit in
the post-mortem and
we realized that white should have kept
his queens on because you know um
you know my king is way more open
i'm sorry
anyways just go back a little bit to
here
here so instead of 95
um we're looking at b4 you know just to
make sure white gets the possibility to
play a5 and fix the black spawn on a6
later and if b4 then rook takes on c1
let's press new variation okay
rook takes c1 queen c1 queen c8 and now
simply queen b2
because that diagonal is really powerful
and black's bishop is reduced to
pure defense which is always not a bad
not a good idea so in this position it
would be real unpleasant for me to
defend this
and after queens came off it became much
easier so that was a draw
so you're in a situation where you're
half a point behind erosion it looks as
though linderman's going to draw
you're not really in control of your own
destiny so much how do you go into
tomorrow's game
same day
same thing i do every day just you know
go and play a game
because i think i said maybe three or
four hours ago that i don't think my
chances are really good this year so i'm
taking it easy this time that's
interesting i mean objectively you're
the strongest player in the competition
and you've won this tournament four
times you know how to win this
tournament and yet you evaluated when
you said that it kind of surprised all
of us here that you would say uh
something that dramatic as your chances
are not very good
please uh explain to us why you said
that
well everybody has been preparing for
this event i mean this is premier
national event and i think people
prepared for at least two three weeks in
advance for this and um
these days the
strength of the players is not that huge
like in the old days between caspar from
the rest of the guys
and now everybody's playing strong
computer moves and seeing all the ideas
so you know these guys have been
waiting for their chance
so do you think it's getting harder and
harder to win these tournaments sure of
course
what about
a statement earlier was by grand master
ben feingold he sort of controversially
said that he thinks that is the younger
generation's turn he thinks that
now is the time that they're taking over
do you think it's that definitive right
now
well okay
but they're getting there
that's all i can
say all right well thanks for j
thanks for joining us and uh wish you
luck in the in your last game thank you
grand master godakovsky uh
playing close to the vest but still
within striking distance of the leaders
if they don't win tomorrow particularly
london draws today then he is still in
the mix here at the u.s championships
guys
i don't believe him for a second
tomorrow he's not going to take it easy
he's going to play for the win well he's
going to play hard he will play hard and
he i think it'll be a little different
he knows the math he wins there's a
decent chance that lenderman and
nicobian will make a draw i mean i don't
know 30 40
that puts him into the three-way tie
tiebreaking a massive favorite in rapid
right he would be a massive favorite
between the three of them in rapid chess
don't you think
yes i do but i mean depending on which
whichever one he got to play but but
doesn't it work like this in case of a
three-way tie
the two players with the worst high
breaks
have to play against each other first
one guy is in the finals already we
don't know who the best tiebreaker is so
in that case he wouldn't be a massive
favorite if you didn't have the best
high rates yeah
in any individual rapid match between
those three players sure if they were
all in a threesome uh playing against
one another right right exactly so um in
fact it's not actually mathematically
possible for him to play against only
one of them right
it's either gonna be a three-way
play-off or he's just out of the party
that's right so
that would be the best you can hope for
and he will be playing for it
and we do have our uh tournament leaders
later still
varujin and cobian
up with maurice next telling us about
his journey in today's game and what he
thought of his chances you rated them
very highly very highly
as he gary
thanks guys i am with grand master of
aruja nakobian who is still
atop the leaderboard at this tournament
but var you must
feel that you let some kind of chance to
slip away today
yeah i got a great position in the
opening and looks like ghada wasn't
familiar with this theory here and got a
big advantage on the clock and
everything's going the right way i
you know had this little exchange
sacrifice got the exchange back
eliminate the bishops
and everything was right and i think god
already mentioned that the crucial
moment was here when i played when he
played b6 after i play here b4 i think i
have very good winning chances here i
just completely forgot this idea to
you know to push this pawn stop a5 and
allow my queen to go to b2 i should keep
the queens on the board because the
queen and two knights together is very
strong here and
it will be very unpleasant here after uh
you know after b4 i think it's uh
you know maybe computer will show
slightly better but i think objectively
it's actually very unpleasant for black
to play so
how did you come into this game your
frame of mind yesterday
you had a difficult game losing the game
after having a great championships eight
in a row and then you lost the game and
now you have to play against gotokomsky
four-time defending champion what was
your mindset coming in today um yeah i
just uh you know i just had to forget
about that game it was just a bad game i
had a really bad day yesterday i just
you know forgot my preparation i just
made that was it just wasn't my day
yesterday so it happens to even the best
players in the world sometimes they'd
have an off day and
i had a really bad day yesterday but
today i played well i got a good
position and uh i just wish i would have
to find this idea before i kind of went
quickly with 95. it just looks so
natural to put the knight on that weak
square but i should play a little bit
more delicately before and then put the
queen on between i had very good winning
chances i think so
sort of a nuance miss here
next round you're going to play against
lenderman who looks like he's going to
draw his game
very close to a draw
and by the way he missed the win in his
game as well just a clean win so it
looks like some missed opportunities
from the two of you at the top and now
you have to play against each other
you're with the black pieces what's your
mindset going into that game yeah i just
uh yeah it's at this point i think for
you know the guys who are leading is
just a lot of pressure so i have to make
sure that uh you don't get the pressure
doesn't get to you you just have to you
know try to play well and
i haven't been in so many of these
situations where the last game means
everything i had once in 2003 similar
situation but uh just have to rest
prepare and try to play my best tomorrow
you remind me of 2003 uh the
championship that you and shabbat
shibalov played and he won that game
what lessons will you take from that
game in order to bolster your chances in
this game yeah at that time i was 19
years old and my first year championship
and i was just a game away from winning
it from my first try and had a very good
position two extra pounds and just i
think
experience was the factor in that game
because you know i could just convert
a very promising position and will be a
champion at 19. but
i think i'm more experienced it's you
know 10 10 11 years passed and i'm a lot
more experienced and
you know i have a great second here so
you know i hope too well to do well
tomorrow well we wish you the best in
the final game of the
grand
tournament
thanks
original cobian yes you have a question
yeah i can't let var escape without
asking one question late in the i i
agree that b4 trying to nail down the
pawn on a6 would have been a good
decision but much later in the game
after there was an opportunity to trade
knights and get a pure knight versus
bishop ending
knight takes d7 let us say
bishop takes d7
knight f3 let us say
i actually evaluated var's chances of
winning this position highly
and yet it seems to me that uh var
himself
didn't think
that he really had much could you
explain to me why you feel that this
position is not
so greatly favorable as i think it is
yeah it's a good question because that's
why i spent a lot of time here after
thinking about my move here i just
was calculating to reach this position
but the problem here is
uh he just doesn't have any weaknesses
that i can try to exploit here so he
just simply plays a king d6
and
king e1 king yeah let's say we bring the
king
bishop e8
king e d2 yeah king c5
king c3 and h6 and
so i have to play b4 yes
um
do you have to play
um
b4 or do could you
knight d4 okay b4 check sure i'll fall
for
exchange six kmd4 and yeah this was one
bishop a4
yeah this was the position that jennifer
and i were looking at and it just felt
to us that
um
even though you don't get to play king
c5 right away this is a kind of a
position where you you have no risk you
don't risk anything and you have moves
like 95 and g4 and
e4 even e4 possibilities with your
knight on e5
and it just felt like you could make
your opponent suffer for quite some time
yeah i agree that probably i should have
played this way i think it's still
objectively a draw but this was better
in fact when i played knight df-3 i was
actually trying to get this position but
i uh you know
i thought he would exchange and i get my
knight on e5 but actually missed the
fact that he plays knight c5 and black
it's better for him to keep the knights
on the board here so this is the detail
that i missed
uh and then actually it's much more
difficult as soon as he brings the
knight on d6 actually it's probably a
draw already i can't do anything there
is no way to entry no entry point there
so i should have exchanged the knights
it's absolutely correct and try to play
that position but i think against kamsky
i don't think i can win this kind of
position because it's uh
there are no good ways to break through
here because bishop is not that bad i
mean optically this looks great for
white but i think bishop is pretty
strong he just goes back on the 8th and
i think should be a draw here
thank you
grand master version of nekobian with
all to play for tomorrow in the
championships a win and he's the u.s
champion guys
i can't wait for tomorrow i mean we're
going to have some great great matches
and uh
i'm i'm happy that nobody really ran
away with the tournament at various
times that we had our leaders but they
got caught and pulled back and the truth
of the matter is that the the players
who have played best in this u.s
championship uh
alex lenderman and vara kopien it's
really wonderful that they're going to
decide it in their game tomorrow unless
unless there's a playoff and let's uh
take a look at our playoff rules
well if the players are two-way tie
which actually is impossible right so
we're actually going to a three-way tie
or no tie yeah if there's a three-way
tie the two players with the lowest tie
breaks will contest an armageddon game
so what happens is those two players can
test an armageddon play game to see who
gets into the finals
of the three-way chart but in case ghada
doesn't win he doesn't come up into a
tie in case of a draw if london
we're right yeah yeah it's okay if
leonardo didn't
make a two-way tie
then bang we're in this situation which
is our number one thing two games of
rapid change that god will win
playing pretty well excellently
exactly so a two-way tie they would
first play two rapid games then it's
that
auction
well actually if the two if the two
players yes exactly they'll just play a
two game rapid match and then there's an
auction with a 45 minute base time
if it's a three-way tie the two players
with the lowest high breaks will contest
an auction game to start an armageddon
game and the winner will then face the
player with the highest tie rates in a
two-game rabbit match again followed by
an opt-in game so it could be up to five
hours of jazz right tomorrow basically
the same as the regular orlando and in
the ladies if
uh the two ladies who are leading both
win they'll be in the same
types of playoffs
simultaneously okay we'll see both
playoffs happening at the same time how
exciting this is great it's great stuff
let's get one play off wow this would be
great maybe like a 40 chance we'll get
it in the championship in 50 in the
ladies
so yeah i guess that means
extra work for us
extra work for maurice
no rest for the weary that's what that
means all right he's stuck working again
by the way guys we should jump to
another game the game between shanklin
uh with him on the black pieces in
friedel is over it's busted i don't mean
that the resigning has happened yet but
it might as well because shanklin has
somehow managed to turn this position
around where he was worse to one where
he is simply winning the move queen f4
has been played first i will go back
just momentarily when he made time
control right around here we saw friedel
just
moving around with his pieces even
though he had time on his clock and he
played very quickly here he played this
check king up queen g4 meantime progress
knight c5 a beautiful move attacking the
bishop but after bishop takes b5 d3 a
nice understanding that the d-pawn meant
more than his b-pawn and now the move h5
this move cost him the game right here
he should have defended with queen to b4
stay tight but he didn't realize with
the danger he was in
maybe again time pressure but it didn't
seem so bad he allowed this pawn to drop
from the board and suddenly the queen
turned into a beast attacking on
different fronts this move attacking the
bishop attacking the pawn rook attacking
pawn big trouble for him queen to b4 now
the sterling move queen to b3 attacking
this rook key move why species are
separated and no longer clustered or
harmonized in any way this rook under
attack separated from the rest of its
army he moved the rook over but that
just allowed the pawn to go to d2 and
the pawn now threatens to become a queen
straight on the board big threat nothing
can nothing can be done now he played
the move queen to f4 and he has many
wins starting by the way we just simply
queen takes bishop that wins very easily
fritz is playing sorry houdini that is
playing the move g5 as an option here
to to just have a refinement is doing
some crazy calculations but i think that
queen takes on b5 will be done and sam
shanklin talk about
the the upset artists he will have
defeated so far a kobian who was
cruising to victory lindemann when he
was cruising to victory and friedel when
he had a chance in the championships a
win by him by fridael would have given
him a tie for first with ocobian and
very likely
right now as we see lendum in there
would have given us a tie with lindeman
as well after this game which should
should theoretically end in a draw
although i'm a little bit confused as to
what the position is on that board right
now
i mean everything's off
so everything will go off the board
after this check and the game will end
in a draw after the move knight to c6
protecting his rook
and that will be a draw so lenderman
will be kicking himself when he finds
out that he could have been sitting on
seven points leading the championship
with white tomorrow against a kobe
okobian having his destiny in his hands
but now as it stands he will be tied for
first going into the last round
again with all to play for guys that's
right the only difference is in that
case if he had actually won this game he
would have been in a situation where a
win or a draw
would be given the championship
whereas now
it's uh he has to win otherwise a draw
will give him just a play off exactly so
could be
and after all uh the only game that
ocobean lost in the tournament was when
he was black and it will be all about
preparation
and we've seen it time and again in this
event that lenderman as preparation has
simply been superb so white
and the championship
must win
and lenderman's a champion and it's um
it's interesting that they're still
playing this on yeah sir i think that
perhaps lenderman is a little bit
frustrated by
the fact that he didn't milk more out of
this and is just kind of like
relaxing by getting these moves in what
do you think yeah well okay uh
i personally don't mind it sometimes i
actually mind when the players agree to
a draw when it's less obvious drawn
and uh amateur players would say well
couldn't he have done this or that
so
why not just play
rook takes rook knight takes rook and
then say okay three versus three knight
versus bishop same side of the board uh
we can make a draw but yeah sure just
play on a few more moves and let the
spectators get the their full money's
worth and it it's it's a draw
that's it it's a draw yes and we you
expect a handshake from those guys any
minute now really
meanwhile how bad is monar i mean sorry
how bad is for dale shankler pretty bad
pretty bad
indeed queen takes a